I don't see Mary start looking for it
again you're not sorry wait come back
- Baron back and we're playing only if
only if I could play only if that was
the best day I ever made right it's in
beta it looked cool I wanted to try it
out now I never thought the party we
place we're going to party that's not
gonna happen
I planning really smooth on parties
don't Eve Oh check what is this game
about ha ha ha
only if I didn't get drunk pass down at
a table pick up in the morning feeling
like [ __ ] yeah we're all the people is
this what what a total player has this
thing with that framing holy [ __ ]
goddamn a night there I mean the rest
look oh it's morning okay sap is there a
note here I told you the cake wasn't a
la what what what it's happening how
what is that where am I
Stephano
yeah noise yeah what sleepy hind me Oh
God not to you again did I hey I don't
goddamn anything about the smoke quit
did I die
oh I died that's what's a run away from
behind me I'm supposed to follow this
little ball this is this like life
except not at all unless you like
following balls which I do
hey ball thanks for saying my life I
just like it's a regular Tuesday by
doing for me I win ah don't get all
right colors shed cups but please do
who's talking to me no [ __ ] no rain
yo you know I would like to play the
guessing game but that thing is a little
bit overrated yes it really wait a
minute how did you get in here no idea
it's just I was invited this party by
this girl and then I just I was being
followed by darkness oh you want to get
out of here alive you're gonna trust me
why okay okay let's start with you
moving over to that mirror mirror I
don't see Mary start looking for it
again you're not sorry wait wait wait
where's the mirror I don't I don't see
the mirror
I'm not ever gonna see it Polly I asked
you [ __ ] up to the [ __ ] Marisa oh you
ugly [ __ ] why don't you take it out and
see Oh mmm
what where are you
I can use this it's not that hard for
you to trust me it's no harm no foul
matter with you you see that key over
there Mikey No then get a tea
I want that voom Oh where's the key why
I can't find the key - wait a minute
snowflake you see that clock behind you
I want to get yo get your eyeball okay
and glue it glue it to the clock how do
i glue it now you've got one minute one
minute to find the key but yeah right
please probably gonna be good thing okay
okay okay get the kid got decay got cake
at cancer leave how do I get the key I
don't see nobody key oh God
drawer I I took a cake mom cause I had
the kid what'd he want
Oh what now I know I'm on drugs before I
was a little space fish what this looks
like this could be away Eddie what what
have I done to you
what'd I do to deserve this is all be
too hasty now son Satta
we don't want you getting hurt now do we
before you get to see your girl under
key what one of these doors lead to your
freedom but sacrifices Samantha graves
while the other door sacrifices yourself
Oh save Samantha grace you evil bastard
most use of of course bunny boy but
we're not playing at you and we're
playing to your heartbeat heartbeat no
tune I'm getting both doors use one key
now it's time to decide whether you're
gonna go for the big dick or small dick
ending Anthony what what if what would
the big or small dick how about no doubt
I'll choose no dick thank you sir I took
the black pawn what am I supposed to do
with you the key is gone now
okay oh okay when in doubt just use the
the rhyming will a doula doff king
kelana cough cough Alana binky banished
uh tup
all right doula choose one part rip all
pieces of still life and bring them to
life with fire how hard can that I burn
the pond it's a riddle
I took us still okay
I took a still life what am I doing with
all these paintings okay I got another
painting another painting not sure I
supposed to do who this painting there
we go
right the black pawns death will create
darkness darkness creates fear and your
fear of death will bring you the key
that shrunk from the black smoke in the
vent mr. Anthony the tiny key
complements your tiny dick quite well
how are you I'm a genius
I guess yeah Matty Mia let's go there
Happiny what I hope you're proud of your
decision at least in line please be the
small deck you rot in hell for the
things you've done to me how you killed
my little girl daughter
I don't get it I don't get it what did I
just play why did I just play okay that
was holy F what the [ __ ]
if anyone could make sense out of that
please let me know enjoy watching
it's a sky khon with today in it I'll
see you the next time love you and
welcome to coming at me in advance over
this week's